it's a visit set amid an ongoing
separation European Parliament president
antonio tajani arrived in Downing Street
for the first time to talk flex it with
the British Prime Minister we want to
spend to the citizens right the citizen
European citizens leaving the UK and the
UK citizens living in European you know
this is the most important message we
want to work together polymers
priorities remain for putting citizens
first to know cherry picking in the
single market and no bilateral talks
between the UK and individual EU member
state any brexit withdrawal deal will
need Parliament's green light in the
meantime Theresa May has unexpectedly
called for a snap election seeking a
stronger mandate before talks begin
president Ione welcomed the move 12 the
new government before the beginning of
the vision a decision if they think is
good not thought about the UK or
suppressed but caught in between all
this are people on both sides of the
channel unsure of what it all means for
them president hi jaani met with NGOs in
London to listen to some of their
concern
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]